big news about Joe Biden's garage as you
all know by now this is where classified
documents were discovered was discovered
in four places one of the four places
just laying around near Biden's Corvette
right there apparently they have been
there four years but Joe isn't worried
at all doesn't think it's a big deal at
all take a look
we're fully cooperating looking forward
to getting this resolved quickly I think
you're going to find there's nothing
there I have no regrets on following
what the lawyers have told me they want
me to do it's exactly what we're doing
there's no there there
no regrets no there there that's not
what he said about Donald Trump last
week Biden said that this is all much to
do about nothing because quote the
documents and the Corvette are in a lock
garage except of course when it wasn't
locked which seems like happened on a
regular basis uh here by the way Hunter
Biden out taking the call for a joyride
with his niece and another young woman
who is yet to be identified Hunter
clearly had access to the garage and
every other room in the house because he
lived there you know keep in mind
Hunter's entire career was based on
selling access to his father to sketchy
foreign Nationals from countries a lot
of whom hate our guts so obviously
Hunter's proximity to easy access to
classified materials a little bit more
than concerning Hunter is not the only
person that had access to Biden's
Delaware Mansion even though Joe spends
almost every weekend there conducting
official business and we have no idea
who visits the home the White House
claiming there's no log of of anybody
that comes anybody that goes let me just
tell you the facts how does a blatant
lie that's like I never talked to Hunter
or anybody about their Farm business
dealings in my family now based on my
interviews with multiple presidents over
the years I know for a fact the secret
service they track every single person
that enters a sitting president's home
there is definitely a record of who has
been in that house over the last two
years they just don't want to release it
now the entire ordeal reeks of
corruption and for the very first time
look at this harassment poll now showing
a majority of you the American people
believe that President Biden committed
an impeachable offense and yet this
country is facing much bigger problems
take a look at your screen look at
Philadelphia and Pennsylvania the
birthplace of our Great American
Republic this is where the Declaration
of Independence was signed this is where
our constitution was written but now
Philadelphia is Hell on Earth violent
crime street gangs lethal drugs have
turned vast areas of the city into a
living Nightmare and it's only getting
worse a dangerous new drug is now
flooding the the market its nickname is
tranq and it is a horse sedative believe
it or not that dealers are mixing with
fentanyl and the results are downright
gruesome it is causing gaping festering
wounds and attics and leaving some
unable to walk already Philadelphia's
overdose deaths are nearly triple where
they were just a decade ago and that
number will almost certainly continue to
climb and sadly it's not just
Philadelphia look at your screen
overdose deaths Nationwide are
skyrocketing now at an all-time high
anybody in the Democratic party equate
this to the chaos of the Border you know
thanks to the mass quantities of cheap
lethal drugs pouring in across that
southern border and a culture of
lawlessness and no bail laws and deep
funding and dismantling police
departments and almost every major city
in this country they are now facing a
crisis what is of Epic Proportions
Democrats don't seem to notice they
don't seem to care what was the last
time you saw a prominent Democrat walk
the streets of West Baltimore you know
Maxine Waters doesn't even live in her
own congressional district in Los
Angeles why because maybe it's too
dangerous and Joe Biden would he ever
dare step foot in some neighborhoods in
Detroit Philly Chicago America cities
they are rotting right in front of our
eyes and Democrats they have their heads
in the sand and in most cases these
cities have been driven into the ground
by democrats that have been running
these cities for a decade after decade
after decade you have thousands now
dying nationally Millions hopelessly
addicted to these drugs the homeless
population is now at record highs
there's no end in sight there's no
effective Solutions there's no local
leadership and yet the oh so
compassionate bleeding heart left is
rewarding them by giving the Democrats
their vote every single election it
Philadelphia has not had a Republican
mayor since 1948. I wouldn't expect one
anytime soon maybe just maybe it's time
for a change hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else